un sens maisonneuve est allé vérifier
c'est vrai qu'on a facilité l'accès des
soins de santé à 300000 québécois
voici les preuves des faits au moment
d'annoncer la candidature de l'ex
présidente de l'ordre des pharmaciens du
québec la chef du pq a vanté les
réalisations son gouvernement qu'en
matière de santé nous avons créé 13
nouveau groupe de médecine familiale
soit les groupes les gmf et surtout 323
milles québécois de plus ont désormais
accès à un médecin de famille
vérification faite les chiffres avancés
par pauline marois sont exactes reste
que 293 mais québécois demeure sur une
liste d'attenté
les délais pour leur trouver un médecin
de famille varient selon leur état de
santé
pour les cas les plus urgents ils
doivent attendre huit mois pour une
personne en pleine santé le temps
d'attentes et d'un an et demi il s'agit
bien entendu d'une moyenne car d'une
région à l'autre
les délais varient en gaspésie par
exemple il faut compter près de 2 avant
se trouver un médecin de famille
bref si plus de québécois ont un médecin
tous ceux qui n'en n'ont pas doivent
faire preuve d'une certaine patience